my strategy to win big brother that is a
great question i want to be the type of
person who is able to go into the
competition knowing exactly what they
want out of it and what i want out of it
is to be able to connect with a lot of
people in the house i'm hoping to win a
few competitions as well but more
importantly i want to bring my charm to
the game and hopefully that's going to
take me as far as i can to the finale
um what kind of personality are you
doing
i typically do not do well with people
who are just disrespectful i don't like
people that interrupt other people i
don't like people that talk over other
people because they think that they need
to be heard and if that's the type of
person i'm going to interact with in the
house i think we might have a problem
but i'm also not the type of person to
get angry i just get petty you're not
confrontational i'm not confrontational
but this is big brother so like you
don't have to be confrontational in
person i can do it behind your back
i just evict you
um
or nomads that's a good question i am in
a very loving healthy relationship for
the last two years now and i don't want
to change any of that so i think for me
it might be like a best friend mass or
like maybe like a best girlfriend as
like i want a sister in the house that i
get along with that's kind of my vibe
uh
why is canada gonna root for you
i think canada will root for me because
they'll realize how clumsy and goofy i
am
and that i'm really here to play a
really good game but also be really
respectful to other people i don't want
to be the type of person who's known um
for being just absolutely rude to other
house guests and i want to play a very
honest and good game i want it to be
very strategic and very calculated and i
think that's what people love in big
brother and that's why we all love this
show is we love people who can come up
with very creative decisions um when
they're going throughout the game and
make big moves as well you want to
entertain canada i would love to
entertain canada
you